this is a storm on Saturn and this is a
New Zealand bar that sells shots of
horse Vsauce Kevin here this is my blue
anyone could play guitar with the
possessed hand electric wristband it
straps onto your arm and sends
electrical signals to your fingers to
move them in precise ways like maybe
filling a cavity on the robot dental
patient it was created for dentistry
schools and has the ability to shake its
head sneeze cough and even choke the
oomphel of palm petroleum was created by
Leonard Solomon and it's a homemade
organ that sounds like this
now let's melt a sponge with sulfuric
acid 662 microbes are brand new to
science that were found living in
bellybuttons my gum increase the size of
your belly by eating this world-record
777 pound hamburger board with jet skis
just try the Seabreacher it's a
submersible watercraft that allows
diving jumping and rolling and there are
models shaped like a dolphin killer
whale and even a spaceship dude this
experimental ultraviolet comic book
comes with a UV torch that reveals
dialogue published in invisible ink find
the link below for more information
Paris City Hall has this optical
illusion outside that covers 1,500
square meters and it took 90 gardeners
five days to put it all together
slo-mo egg explosion hello and now some
short films the guy who made the Mega
Man stop-motion featured in mind blow
thirteen now has an epic Final Fantasy 7
battle
not working film sends us down the
pac-man highway finally this short
manages to combine Terminator 2
animation stop-motion and an original
8-bit inspired electronic music track
I'm gonna leave you with a riddle
John and Mary were sitting in their
family room one night while John was
watching TV
his wife Mary was reading suddenly the
power went out and John decided to go to
bed but Mary kept reading without the
use of artificial light how did Mary
continue to read
leave your answer in the comments below
and the first person to name the songs
in the oomphel upon patron iam Final
Fantasy and Terminator 2 videos will be
our genius of the week so good luck and
as always thanks for watching